stranger things season 4 to me is the
best season since the first given that
season 2 had a couple rough patches and
season 3 was fun despite the writing
being a bit ridiculous at times with
season 4 The Duffer brothers gave
themselves an extra year to work on the
season and I think the quality really
shows through the final product we have
a gripping narrative that not only so
introduces a lot of new interesting
developments but also delves deep into
the lore and gives us a lot of answers
to questions that have been burning a
hole in us for years Revelations like
one actually being vechna the lab
Massacre not being caused by 11. and
vechna being the one that creates the
Mind flare and the overall essence of
The Upside Down are all excellent
directions to take the story the overall
concept of The Upside Down is so rich
and intriguing that we as an audience
have been craving for some backstory for
the upside down and the fact that the
Duffer Brothers not only deliver on that
but exceed it is impressive this reminds
me of Game of Thrones season 8 where
fans were clamoring for some backstory
for the white walkers but were
ultimately denied and the writers said
nothing with it but here for stranger
things it's a breath of fresh air to
feel more than satisfied with the
writing of the show and it hasn't gone
down in quality over the years then on
the subject of over the years the acting
is at its best from will still
delivering scenes with extreme emotional
depth characters like Lucas and Dustin
who haven't had a lot of deep material
to work with prior who managed to rise
to the occasion especially Dustin with
that heartbreaking final scene where he
tells Eddie's father that he died and
characters like 11 still proving that
there are magnificent highlights and
this isn't even mentioning the standout
performance of the season with
sadistan's portrayal of Max the way she
showcases the sheer complexity of
feeling grief regrets and overall having
so many feelings chipping away at our
mental well-being is crazily impressive
then this is also tied into her
character having a spectacular Arc of
escaping vecta and then even going back
to face him again despite what she's
been through she really steals the show
this season for the Hawkins storyline
where the death Brothers do with it is
completely riveting from the creepy and
shocking horror of people getting
crumpled up like paper throwing our
characters down a deep Rabbit Hole of an
intriguing mystery the Striking
Revelations that are brought about by
crazy twists and there's even some great
and original action like with Eddie
ripping a guitar solo to lure in bats
there's really no down moments during
the entire stretch of time in Hawkins
and it makes the other plot lines like
with Mike and Company and Hopper being
stuck in Russia feel a bit less in
comparison which this also leads into a
couple small gripes I have in season 4
because currently every character within
Hawkins is perfectly utilized and fills
a specific function that has a men's
purpose but when you look at the pizza
van Adventure Mike Will and Jonathan
fall into the backgrounds and more so
Jonathan because he essentially just
turns into a taxi driver this season and
this is inherently just where the
characters are left off because being so
far away from Hawkins and separated from
11 doesn't really give these guys much
to do then to even Compound on this
feeling of disconnection Jim Hopper for
being in a Russian prison doesn't feel
like it fits well into the story
especially since how does him going
through a portal on Hawkins teleport him
to Russia wouldn't he just end up in the
upside down version of the mall or did
he not actually go through the portal
and was captured in Hawkins which also
wouldn't make sense because the EOS Army
was surrounding the mall currently it
feels like they left us intentionally
vague because they know this development
is illogical but would have gave Hopper
more of a purpose within the season
would be for his character to instead be
trapped in the upside down by going
through the portal at the end of season
3 and is then captured by vechna to then
be utilized as a hostage to manipulate
11. I know this is a drastically
different idea than having hopper in
Russia but the alternative is having a
crazy and ridiculous plot for Joyce and
Murray to go to Russia and break Hopper
out of prison that aspect is just as
absurd as in season 3 where there's an
entire underground Russian base in
Hawkins and kids are able to infiltrate
it like breaking in and out of this
really scary prison was far too easy
then the The Duffer Brothers try to
infuse this plotline with some Purpose
By the Russians capturing part of the
Mind flayer which I have no idea how
they manage that given that it's a
gaseous entity and it seems like it's
only there so that the good guys can
destroy it to help everyone back in
Hawkins which they conveniently kill it
when everyone in the upside down is
about to die so as it stands this feels
like a bit of a contrived way to give
Hopper's plotline more purpose but I
feel like this won't be as much of an
issue in season 5 because everyone is
back in Hawkins again and the connection
will probably be much stronger between
every character then from another small
issue is that the season felt a bit
bloated given that there were like six
to seven active subplots going at a time
in some aspects of those plot lines
didn't feel very essential for the story
one of those being L getting bullied at
school for an extended period of time
for this whole development there's not
much of an impact on the plot since L
just gets plucked out of confinement and
was sent to training not to mention that
this bullying development felt a bit
redundant since they did it again in
11's training flashback this isn't a
major issue and there's one clever thing
that The Duffer Brothers do to alleviate
this problem of juggling so many
subplots which is the usage of parallel
editing and for people who don't know
parallel editing is separate scenes
intercut together to present a storyline
for multiple perspectives an example of
this is Robert and Nancy interviewing
Henry's father while Max is being
pursued by vecna or in the first episode
where the DND matches playing out during
Lucas's basketball game this energizes
the pace of the show and what makes
these intricate scenes even better is
the editing because to me a well-placed
match cut is pure dopamine for my brain
because of how clever it is but overall
by using parallel editing it Bridges the
gap between so many subplots and allows
the writers to tell stories
simultaneously on top of presenting
these scenes in a much more creative
manner so all these subplots never
really feel like a burden because of how
well paced they are and their coherent
Synergy throughout the episode going
back to the Hawkins plotline there's one
more aspect I want to talk about in the
season that elevates it over the others
which is the r of danger that surrounds
everyone since 11 isn't in Hawkins to
protect our beloved characters makes a
stake significantly higher because they
can't hide behind the leaven anymore
this was as well the same case with
season 2 which I think also did a great
job with having higher Stakes but that
only lasts an episode and a half since
11 comes back from a brief vacation and
things don't start getting dicey towards
the end of the season that feeling of
helplessness and having to overcome a
seemingly impossible task is applied to
the entirety of season four because the
threat starts much sooner along with the
fact of our characters having to figure
out the mystery by themselves this kind
of writing where you can't point to a
clear and easy solution and puzzles the
audience until being wowed by the answer
is to me my favorite aspect of writing
and The Duffer Brothers managed to do
this in almost every episode that's why
the scene where our characters cleverly
outsmarting vechna where Max escapes
using music she loves was one of the
best scenes in the show it's immensely
satisfying on top of the execution in
season 4 being epic as well then going
back to the higher Stakes it immerses
every scene with so much tension because
at any point one of our characters could
die even early on when Steve gets
dragged down into the upside down by
himself and gets ravaged by bats you
question his safety I know he probably
won't ever die but there was definitely
a moment there where he questioned
whether or not he would survive that
situation which that's great although
it's kind of miraculous that the bites
from the bats didn't have any alien
diseases but whatever I don't want to
think about that because Steve is the
best character in the show and he's
A-Okay he just might give Nancy alien
AIDS in season five I'm sure that's
exactly what people would want overall I
think the season exudes such a high
quality and it's surprising to me that
stranger things has about the same
budget of Obi-Wan per episode but
stranger things has both a much better
production value and is significantly
longer this allows for The Duffer
Brothers to do a deep dive with their
writing despite some of the subplots
feeling a bit disconnected with a lack
of unifying purpose but now that
everyone is together for season five I'm
sure the Duffer Brothers will come up
with a better way to utilize every
character more efficiently and since
there will be an apocalypse of sorts I
doubt 11 will be able to protect
everyone so that are of danger probably
won't evaporate thank you for watching
and let me know what you think about
season 4 in the comments